okay uh my name is andres molano
i'm a high school student from mexico
city and i'm
currently doing the yamiche logic
bioinformatics research fellowship
program
i'm really passionate about biochemistry
systems biology and neuroscience and i'm
really interested in the biological
mechanisms that underlie the development
of
neuro degenerative diseases
namely alzheimer's disease and my
project
is titled at least for the moment
evaluating the role of microglial cells
in the pathogenesis and progression of
alzheimer's disease
uh and my mentor is doctor heartbeat
core
so alzheimer's disease is an
irreversible and progressive brain
disorder
that results in the development of
cognitive deficits and clinical dementia
it is characterized by the development
of two pathological hallmarks
the first being the development of
extracellular amyloid obliques
and the other one being uh intracellular
neurofibrillary tangles
uh although these are uh widely regarded
as the two main pathological harmonics
of alzheimer's disease
scientists still don't truly know how
they
link to each other and because of these
uh
they believe that there might may be
other pathological mechanisms that
underlie uh well yes the pathogenesis
and progression of alzheimer's disease
and it is widely known that
patients with alzheimer's disease show
an increased inflammatory response
uh after they start developing amyloid
beta plagues
and a this inflammatory response has
also been shown to exacerbate
the development of both neurofuel
rectangles
or towel pathologies as well as the
development of these amyloid beta
plagues
and for these reasons some scientists
believe that
inflammation might be the third core
pathology of alzheimer's disease
thus providing a link between the other
two main pathological hallmarks
um well inflammation in the brain is
mediated by microglial cells which are
the brain's resident macrophages
which are part of our body's immune
system
and because of this they have been shown
to mediate their inflammation in the
in the brain by the secretion of
pro-inflammatory cytokines
uh and yes i had said uh so scientists
believe that this uh
neuroinflammation mediated by microglial
cells might constitute
this link between the development of
amyloid beta plaques
and the further development of
neurofibrillary tumors
so for this project i wanted to evaluate
uh how the transcription of microglial
cells
are buried uh through across a across
well like ph uh azimuth aged
and i used these data set from the study
transcriptomic profiling of microglia
industrial astrocytes throughout aging
from the journal of near inflammation
so in here they used a wild type and apb
ps1 mice
abbp is when mice uh show an elevated
uh development of amyloid beta plagues
uh because they like overproduce the
amyloid beta peptide
so they show a higher development of the
of these plagues in here
uh and they used 58 samples so uh
they have the uh sequence of
transcription of both microglia and
astrocytes
uh in both wild type and 80 mice the ad
mice are the
uh alzheimer's this is more mice so the
app is one mice
uh and they will be yeah they sequence
the transcription at five different
uh time points so two months four months
six months
nine nine months and twelve months uh
and in the end they had 58 samples
i believe that the data from this data
set provides
valuable information regarding
microglial activation
in response to aging with amyloid beta
pathologies because like i'd say
uh these mice apb ps1 mice they show
elevated levels of
amyloid beta plagues and so we can
really see
how this amulet beta plates are changing
uh the yeah the transcriptomic profile
of microglial cells
and to see whether there is truly uh
under inflammatory response uh due to
the development of these
pathologies
uh so based on these files they provided
i decided to just focus on the
microglial cells
i performed an rna-seq pipeline
uh so i quantify the gene expression
levels of microbial cells
plus uh both across uh the wild type and
the ad mice
and just as with any uh rna-seq pipeline
i pre-process the data then i mapped the
guaranteed transcripts to the organism's
reference genome
and i then quantify the abundance of
reads aligned to the reference genome
so that i could get a gene expression
table
in read counts uh inverted counts
uh and well yes i obtain the expression
levels in raw read guns as an output
and then i used this gene expression
table as an input for several
differential expression analysis
uh and well yes based on this gene
expression
table that i got i performed the
following differential expression
analysis
using these egg two so the first one was
young ad versus old ap
so this will allow me to see uh how the
transcription of microglial cells
uh vary in pathological conditions as a
mice
age then young wildlife versus old wild
type
this constitutes a reference to which i
could compare the first
differential expression analysis as to
see whether
minds that are not in pathological
conditions exhibit the same changes
across
aging or if the changes that i observed
in the first differential expression
analysis
are just inherent to the disease oh
yes then i did young wildlife versus
young id
uh to see whether the transcriptomic
differences uh between microglial cells
in pathological and physical
physiological conditions
arise uh like from a young age whether
they arises in my speaking to
to age when they are older and then
these uh
last one uh old wild type versus old adi
uh
to see uh the well yes the
transcriptomic differences between old
wild type mice and all the
mice uh and to see like uh what are the
main uh
physiological differences between these
two
clinical groups um and just to
uh like explain how i defined young
young mice as those that were uh
two four and six months old because
based on what i've
read uh these might start developing
amulet paid up lakes
around uh six to seven months old when
they are six to seven
seven months old and so i thought they
would be
uh based on this observation i should
include the the young mice
uh s246 model of mice so that
built mice uh would be those that showed
a
truly elevated level of amyloid beta
please
and then after performing the
differential basic differential
expression analysis
uh i filtered the differential
expression i selected the differentially
expressed genes
for each analysis and you can really uh
like i think that this provides us an
insight into uh when the uh
transcriptomic changes so if you could
call them that
all right so you can see that between
the young wildlife and the young lady
we only have uh nine
differentially expressed genes so that
really tells us that
they are rather similar to each other
uh and that the physiological
differences appears in my speaking to
age
and then when we compare the young lady
to the old av
we can see that there is a greater uh
there's a greater number of
differentially expressed genes
in comparison to the young wild type
versus old wild type of course we
also see a rather elevated number but
this one is larger so
that maybe tells us that there is a
greater like
physiological divergence in terms of the
transcriptome
yeah and so based on these
differentially expressed express genes
that i had gotten
i performed four different uh principal
component analysis with those selected
genes so with the differentially
expressed
genes so uh this one in here
uh is from uh the young lady versus old
lady
so here we can see that uh the old ada
mice are clustering to the
left side of the block whereas the young
mice or those from two to
two four and six month old mice are
clustering in here
uh so these are all ab mice uh so here
we found that
one of the six month old he's clustering
like towards the old mice uh which
honest
honestly isn't like that surprising
because as i had said
this might start developing the america
pathologies around like six to seven
months old
and so maybe it is my starting
development developing these pathologies
when
uh it was perhaps like uh
younger because yeah of course it varies
uh it isn't like
that when they are six months old it
starts uh
but yeah then here i perform the young
wildlife versus the old wild type
again uh here you can see that the two
four and six month old cluster on here
whereas a 90 12 month old class around
here
but we don't see like such uh like it
isn't that polarized
and then from the uh differentially
expressed genes
uh i selected those that showed uh
well using log2folk those that were uh
like over express and those that were
underexpressed
uh based on these differential
expression analysis and i could see that
uh in the young ap versus the old lady
and also in the old wild diapers the old
lady
we can see an increase in the activity
of neurotrophic degranulation
neurotrophic activation involving immune
response
neurotropical mediated immunity and here
what we can see those same things and
then we can also
see here uh the inflammatory response uh
positive regulation of acute
inflammatory response
positive regulation of inflammatory
response regulation of inflammatory
response
positive regulation of cytokine
production so these are all mechanisms
involved in immune processes and
inflammatory mechanisms
which reinforces what we have what i had
stated in my
introduction uh
and when we compare that up so when we
compare these differences
to uh the differences that arise when
comparing the young wildlife resource
wildlife
we see that in here there isn't really
an inflammatory response or like
an increase uh in the immune processes
uh
so that really tells us uh that this is
uh
inherent to the pathological conditions
because we are not seeing that in here
uh and yeah as i had said the main
difference between the wild type mice
and the app ps1 mice
is that the ladder uh over produced
amyloid beta
and so they showed an increase they
showed increased levels of these
amyloid beta plagues so this could tell
us that
the aggregation of these amyloid beta
plaques likely constitutes the cause
of microglial immune activation
and as i had previously said uh
these uh immune activation this
neuroinflammatory response in the brain
has been shown to exacerbate the
development of neurofibrillary tangles
so this really reinforces these uh like
a link between uh amyloid beta plates
and refrigerated angles and
that thing is like this near
inflammatory response
and yeah so based on these mechanisms
that
were uh the most uh significant so
neurotropical degranulation retrograde
activation
neurotrophic mediated immunity i tried
to research a little bit about the
water neutrophils i'm sorry i think that
i got said neurotropics it's neutrophil
uh so neutrophils are the most abundant
leukocytes so they are
white blood cells in circulation in the
circulation
they modulate immune processes and
they've been shown to play important
roles in pathological inflammation
and they are granulocytes which means
that uh
their cells uh they are type of white
blood cells that contain specific
granules which are some like vesicles
that contain
uh cytotoxic molecules as well as for
inflammatory cytokines
and then when they became activated
they well yeah they can produce reactive
oxygen species which also
promote inflammation and it can also
lead to phagocytosis and the secretion
of pro-inflammatory cytokines
um and uh
well yes and so what's next
so as i get said i'm may induce the
expression of
and the secretion of pro-inflammatory
cytokines via
microglial cells in alzheimer's disease
but now i want to uh
investigate like what are the cellular
cellular and molecular mechanisms
that regulate the expression of these
cytokines
and long non-coding rnas are key gene
expression regulators in both innate and
adaptive immunity processes
the function of these molecules in
pathological processes however removes
are largely unknown and they have been
shown to regulate the indus
inducible expression of cytokines after
immune activation
so now i want to answer this question uh
what are the roles of think long
non-coding rnas in the pathogenesis and
disease preparation of alzheimer's
disease
are they involved in the regulation of
microglial activation states and thinner
inflammation in alzheimer's disease
uh yes so that is all well thank you for
your attention